et pour notre rendez-vous juniors on
retrouve mélanie poquet et cette semaine
vous êtes partis au château de breteuil
à choisel pour des activités couture oui
c'est un atelier qui se répète à chaque
vacances scolaires mais avec bien sûr
qui a mis un thème différent
pour ces vacances là sophie c'est la
responsable elle vous emmène à venise et
au carnaval plus exactement être quoi et
l'alliage et des costumes et de la
couleur c'est génial et donc les enfants
sont invités à créer une partie de
costumes alors des couronnes des
chapeaux des prochaines des tutus
certains ont créé des ailes de papillons
des ailes de dragon moi j'en ai vu
certains c'est magic et c'est surtout ce
qui est super intéressant c'est qu'on
peut utiliser toutes les matières qui
veulent écouter
il commence à découper du carton par
exemple les formes de masquer les formes
de chapeau je réalise moi même chaque
format mon idée et les enfants s'en
servent comme un pochoir
ensuite il colle du tissu dessus il
décore en collant des paillettes des
plumes des perles des pompons des
pétales de fleurs en tissu alors
l'atelier s'adresse aux plus jeunes dès
4 ans mais aussi aux plus grands jusqu'à
14 ans lorsque commença se déroule à ce
que la différence d'âge de pas trop trop
importante à la non déjà faut savoir
quelle est la taille est encadré par
deux adultes notamment sophie et
s'adapte à l'âge de l'enfant les pubs
les plus petits font que du collage on
va dire les plus grands vont pouvoir
travailler avec des aiguilles du fils
faire un bien marcher leur imagination
certaines créations se font en 30
minutes certaines l'une à revoir 2a et
les enfants au final soit assez content
écoutez les j'avais vu astérix obélix
mission angleterre et bah j'avais vu
plein d'angleterre a été belle avec la
comprenait j'ai décidé d'un fan on a mis
de carton à arette la conjoncture après
on a bien tenu et on m'a collé des
gommettes et des paillettes
je trouve que j'ai bien moi j'aime bien
ce qui est bien c'est que cet atelier
taf rampe apprend plein de choses déjà
bien de ça après du coup tu peux ramener
chez toi alors pour ce qui est des
informations pratiques les parents vous
pouvez déposer vos enfants en fonction
de leurs envies et s'ils veulent faire
l'atelier et vous en attendant vous
allez visiter le château
l'atelier commence quand l'enfant arrive
c'est à dire qu' il n'y a pas d'horaires
fixes à respecter sauf 14h 17h30 qu'il
l'amplitude horaire de l'atelier s'est
ouvert tous les jours pour les tarifs
vous comptez 3 à 4 euros en fonction de
ce que veut réaliser l'enfant ça se
rajoute à l'entrée du château
mais comme je lui ai dit tout à l'heure
pas besoin de réservation et bien bon
merci beaucoup mélanine va représenter
ces ateliers costumes donc on le
rappelle a réalisé durant toutes les
vacances scolaires et pourquoi pas une
idée pour préparer mardi gras qui arrive
à la fin du mois